fox news alert maryland's governor larry
hogan tightening his state's covet 19
restrictions now
the new rules include a 10 p.m curfew
for all bars and restaurants
capacity limits at stores salons and
houses of worships will also be lowered
hospital and nursing home visits will be
suspended no fans
allowed at sporting events maryland has
reported more than a thousand new cases
a day
for over two weeks governor hogan joins
us live this morning governor thank you
very much good to have you with us this
morning
good morning good to be with you it's
good to have you with us i think these
are
things that everybody has wanted to
avoid i would imagine that you would
hope to avoid them as well
uh why do you think this is the best
course of action
at this point well so you know we've
been doing really well both on our
economic recovery
and on the virus we were better than 43
other states we've had our
economy 100 open since july or august
but now we're seeing the virus
unfortunately doesn't recognize
state borders and it's spiking out of
control all across the country in all 50
states
we've hit our our largest peak ever
we've been over 2 000
2 300 cases a couple days in a row and
the biggest concern we have is our
hospitalizations which is also happening
in many many states
we're at 90 capacity we have a number of
hospitals that are over capacity
and you know we had 25 deaths in the
past 24 hours
we have you know a person dying every
minute in america but
one every hour here in the state of
maryland so a couple of
conflicting inputs on your
action one coming from the montgomery
county executive
mark elrich who says the governor had
strong words but i don't think the steps
that he
took match the urgency of his words we
must take significant measures
to slow the spread and then the director
of national federation of independent
businesses
michael halleran has a different take he
says it's a very sad day for maryland
businesses
it will be very tough pill to swallow
for so many of the state's
jobs creators what do you say to both of
those individuals about your decision
well look you're never going to make
everybody happy these are terrible
decisions there it's a choice between a
bad choice and a bad choice
uh and and look i'm a lifelong small
businessman that only ran for governor
to help small businesses grow and to put
more people to work
but we're also trying to keep our
hospitals from overflowing and keep
people from getting
uh you know losing their businesses or
losing their lives and so we're trying
to find that balance
you know a recent poll said 89 percent
of the people in in amer
in maryland uh believe that we've got it
just about right there's a few
on one side to think we're not doing
enough and there's a few on the other
side i think we're doing too much but
i don't really care what people think
we're just making the decisions based on
all the best advice
and you know we're hoping to get it
right so i know you were on the call
yesterday with president-elect joe biden
about coronavirus what was your takeaway
from that
and you know how do you see him handling
this
any differently than what we've had in
the past
right well so we had a really productive
meeting with the vice president pence
and the white house coronavirus task
force on tuesday
uh what we had what i thought was a
productive uh uh
meeting yesterday with vice president
biden and senator
harris this was the executive committee
of the national governors association so
it was five republicans and five
democrats
they were mostly in listening mode they
didn't talk a lot about
their plans or how they might change but
we thought it was important
uh the governors have been on the front
line of fighting this battle since uh
you know for nine months now and we we
gave us a chance to tell them
uh what what we saw going on and what
what were the things that we needed to
continue and
some of the things that we thought we
needed help on like we want to get the
next stimulus package some kind of
compromise between
democrats and republicans we're making
great progress on the vaccine
with operation warp speed it's one of
the biggest successes of the
of the current administration but we
want to make sure that nobody's dropping
the balls that's where
as we're you know going through this
transition
governor hogan thank you very much good
luck to you and good to have you with us
thank you martha